three gasser bonjour bonjour merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation dans la
matinale de rtl france alors aujourd'hui
avec des confrères à vous alerter sur
les conséquences de la crise sanitaire
sur les enfants qu'est ce que vous avez
observé très concrètement
concrètement nous avons observé une
diminution bien entendu du nombre de
consultations est du nombre de
consultations de prévention avec
notamment une diminution de la
vaccination et de toutes les
vaccinations
d'autre part une diminution des prises
en charge de pathologies particulières
telles que la dyslexie tels que
l'obésité puisqu'il y ait moins de de
prise en charge de ces petits patients
et donc cet impact est non négligeable
sur leur vie quotidienne
et puis sur leur vie psychologique vous
savez le port du masque aussi le rapport
avec l'autre le rapport physique le
rapport est quelque chose d'important et
donc le confinement a eu un impact il
est ce confinement est mieux en attaque
sur tout le monde
on a beaucoup parlé de nos personnes
fragiles mais on a souvent oublié nos
petits patients et nos enfants est donc
cette tribune alerte à la fois sur
l'urgence d'avoir une prise en charge et
d'avoir je dirais un blanc de santé de
l'enfant demain en france
et puis bien entendu la place la casse
de nos pédiatre puisque cette leur ce
rapport de l'institut général
deux des affaires sociales dit que la
pédiatrie doit être non pas une
spécialité de de premier recours de deux
de proximité mais plutôt une spécialité
de reco et ça nous le défendons parce
que ce n'est pas ça aujourd'hui qu'il
faut il faut une expertise de proximité
et c'est expertise de proximité et bien
c'est no pédiatre qui peuvent le faire
au mieux
parce que c'est des professionnels qui
sont dédiés à la petite enfance
est-ce que c'est pédiatre ils ont
finalement étaient un peu laissés à eux
mêmes pendant sept pendant les
confinements notamment avec avec ses
enfants en difficulté nécessairement un
petit peu puisque on s'est surtout
occupé des personnes fragiles et ces
personnes fragiles c'était plutôt les
personnes âgées les personnes en
situation de handicap et puis certaines
choses telles que l'obésité
l'hypertension artérielle
ce que l'on voit assez peu chez l'enfant
donc nécessairement c'est une population
dont ton c'est un peu moins occupés et
ça veut dire quoi pour les parents qui
nous écouterait ça veut dire
qu'aujourd'hui il faut que leur enfant
est bien ils aillent voir un pédiatre ou
alors vous demander au gouvernement par
exemple de faire des suivis dans les
écoles qu'est ce que vous préconisez
aujourd'hui je crois qu'aujourd'hui il
faut que tous les enfants de france voit
un pédiatre à des tâches clés de la vie
alors il ya d'une part tous les
nourrissons bien entendu qu'il doit être
suivi par un pédiatre et puis c'est vrai
que nous n'avons pas cette pédiatre
aujourd'hui en france et donc il faut
que ces enfants voient assez ask les
deux en six ans des pédiatres pour voir
si le développement
l'enfant est et bien et bien là et qu'il
n'y a pas de retard particulier pour que
nous n'ayons pas de retard dans la prise
en charge de ces enfants qui s'ils ont
un accompagnement peuvent rattraper ce
retard
à tout âge de la vie peut-être une
dernière question pour conclure vous
avez aussi observé des différences selon
les territoires entre les impacts de la
crise sanitaire sur les enfants bien
entendu mais mais mais les impacts sont
sont différents en fonction des
territoires mais parce que les
territoires sont différents il ne faut
pas faire dire aux études des choses
qu'elles ne peuvent pas dire
donc aujourd'hui je pense qu'il faut que
les setu de compte nous avons un
problème de liaison bien allez-y pour
conclure notamment aux pédiatres
ouais allez-y pour qu'on gagne qu'on ait
l'air d'un prêt de livres à pardon je
dirais que pour conclure il faut
absolument que les pouvoirs publics
accompagnent la petite enfance et
accompagne nos professionnels qui
s'occupe de ses enfants et notamment les
pédiatres donc développer la démographie
pédiatrique et développer aussi les
collaborateurs la possibilité d'avoir
des collaborateurs à nos médecins
pédiatres pour qu' il puisse voir au
plus au mieux le l'ensemble des enfants
en france
merci beaucoup patrick gasser d'avoir
répondu à nos questions ce matin je le
rappelle vous êtes présidente du
syndicat à venir ce petit